uh so hello everyone uh my name is Maria
and today I'll will be talking about the
power of
prototyping let me start with a short
introduction uh I am a senior delivery
manager at Epsilon which in practice
means that I am supporting our clients
in creating new products or enhancing
tools that already exist uh and I'm
working mostly with big corporations uh
where we are creating internal tools for
their teams and one of the most
important aspects of my job is to
support our team to create successful
tools and for me a tool is successful if
first of all it is being used because
only if this first condition is met we
can talk about your product bringing
value and today I'll be talking mostly
from my own personal experience and I
would like to start with a short story
you can see a spoiler here it won't be a
success
story um and it starts started as a
typical project so and there was a
manager who had this great idea for a
new uh tool that he wanted to introduce
for his colleagues and he started
development on his own um around after a
year he realized that he would need some
help from more experienced developers to
fix a few bugs and also Implement more
complex features so he decided to
contact us we started working together
uh but he was our only point of contact
so he was the one deciding on the
priorities uh he was also validating our
work so this is why we asked him a few
times if it would be possible for us to
talk with the users you know mostly to
understand the product better but also
uh maybe to suggest some
improvements but uh this manager was
very hesitant about it so he always
repeated not yet you know let's finish
this one additional functionality or
let's improve this one small feature um
so we continued the
development and uh after additional of
three months we released the first
version of the
application and only then uh we started
talking with the users we were able to
meet with them uh to see how they're
interacting with the application and
also ask them few questions and um as a
result of those meetings we prepared a
report here you can see the result of
this report so nine out of 10 people had
problems with visability and in the end
they told us that they won't be using
the application in a current state
on the next slide you can see a few more
detailed comments but they're quite
similar so people were mentioning that
the app is over complicated and it is
very hard to use it without proper
training so after over a year of
development altoe we created something
that people were not going to use so as
you can guess the project was closed and
the app was never really on the
production so of course after a project
like this we started asking ourselves
you know what could we have done better
and the first answer that we had is that
we should probably talk with the users
sooner so of course even before
contacting us this manager could have
some talks with the users he could just
you know deploy the first version of the
application and ask them to provide
feedback but you know maybe also we
could be more pushy when asking for
contact with the
users um so that's why currently when
I'm uh starting any project this is the
one phrase that I'm trying to follow and
I'm trying to convince you know all the
clients to release as fast as possible
and to be able to do this you need to
start simple so for me the best way uh
to be able to release fast is to start
with a
prototype and when I say prototype uh
I'm in the first version of your
application with only a few main
functionality fully developed uh but it
is important here to focus on the
default user path so whenever you have
your business case you know just focus
on the one main thing you want your
users to be able to do in your
application and and then uh you know
strip it out of everything else there
are of course some things that can be
mocked to just show to the users that it
is possible to implement it but it does
not need to be fully
functional uh because only then you can
have something that you can show to your
users in just a few weeks rather than
few months and now some of you may ask
me what is this amazing tool that you're
are using to have prototype in just a
few weeks uh and in our case especially
for data driven applications shiny would
be uh the tool that we are using there
are probably many reasons that a lot of
people from shiny team could share but
for us it is first of all the fact that
you can prototype very fast so you don't
need to have any web development
knowledge it is enough to know R and
shiny will take care of everything else
for you uh the second point is that you
have a lot of outof the Box packages
like bsle that was just presented um and
also there are even ready to use
templates that you can download like on
our ABS web page you can find some of
them and then there can be your starting
point uh another point is that you can
deploy very fast uh in shiny it is very
easy to deploy your app especially if
you have posit connect then it's just
one click of a button but there are also
alter Alternatives there uh and the last
point that in my opinion is
underappreciated is the ease to show the
real data and of course on one side you
have a lot of RIT to use components that
are uh allowing you to create uh you
know an interactive application that
your users can use to to explore the
data but also we can pre-process the
data directly in R so you don't need to
have any additional tools and we all
know that usually when we are starting
our project the data is not perfect and
it needs some cleanup uh or
modifications and I would like to focus
a bit more on this last point and tell
you why uh I think that you know it is
important to show the real data to the
users when you are even just prototyping
just let
me so first of
all it allows the users to focus on the
functionalities rather than discussing
the data in accuracy uh so I've been in
a situation that I had to present a
prototype with only mock data and it
still brought value but we spent a lot
of time discussing why this 15 is not 17
and even if I explain to the users that
the data is mocked then you know I had
to explain myself when do I where where
do I plan to dat data from so in the end
they were just focusing on this one part
uh another point is that it is just
easier to compare to the current process
so whenever you are introducing a new
tool in your organization you are
probably trying to support or even
replace a pro process that already
exists uh even if this is just you know
sending an Excel file to your manager
but then um if you are showing the users
the same data in both places they can
easily compare uh those two ways of
doing the same task and give you a
better
feedback and last point is that um it
allows to select the best way to present
the data so we we all know that if we
would use some default um sets like Iris
you know your data will look probably
decent but then when you're starting to
useing production data it may um differ
a lot so one of the examples I have is
that we created a big table in one of my
projects with uh row and cells colored
based on some business IC and it looked
very well with the mock data we were
very happy with it but then when we
started using the production data and
like the colors were all over the place
it was just not possible to read this
and we had to completely redesign uh
this
feature so let's now assume that you
know we were able to build a prototype
we are even able to uh show the real
data so what is
next so next we need to start talking
with the
users and today I'll be talking about uh
two ways of gathering user feedback that
work best in my
projects uh so I'll start with user
interviews and then I will go to user
workshops uh so when I say user
interviews I mean a set of one-on-one
meetings uh between the users and the
interviewer and here it is important uh
first of all for the meetings to be
really one-onone uh because only then
the user can fully focus on the uh
application
and also you know um answer honestly for
questions so if his manager is in the
room it will be a bit more difficult
sometimes to do
so um the second point is that um the
user has to interact with the
application so this is not us showcasing
the app and just explaining new features
it is just sending a link to a user and
asking them to perform some actions um
and is good to keep the instructions as
simple as possible so for example avoid
saying something like could you please
go to the page free and just edit data
in the row for it is much better to
focus on this business aspects so for
example asking something like uh could
you please uh modify the number of
camomile shampoos in the magazine in
Chicago in November because then you can
see how easy or difficult it is first
for the user to find the information
about this camomile shampoo but then
also to modify
it and uh another point is to limit the
explanations to minimum
and it may be challenging at first
especially if you see people struggling
with the app you know you want to help
them but it is crucial to just observe
and learn from it um and the last Point
here is to remember to give
opportunities to provide open feedback
uh so one thing that I'm always doing is
uh I'm asking the users to speak aloud
about the thinking process uh because
then they can you know tell me not only
what they are doing and why but they are
also sharing their expectations quite
often and this is a great source of
information on what how you can improve
your
application and also after this first
part of the interview so after you know
the user stopped interacting with the
application and Performing those tasks
it is good to save some time to ask
additional questions uh and here the
Only Rule is to just you know avoiding
suggesting the answer uh so I would
avoid questions like you know don't you
think that this functionality is great
or the most useful it is much better to
ask uh you know which of the
functionalities is the most useful or
even better how um often are you going
to use different functionalities
here uh so this was this first part
about those one-on-one meetings user
interviews and now I will go to the
second part about user workshops um
which is a set of meetings with a larger
group of users uh ideally five to seven
but I think 10 is still manageable and
all those meetings people are working
with the application individually uh
they are then sharing their experience
which later discussed and some
improvements are
suggested uh and on those meetings it is
good to split into sessions focus on one
functionality uh here you can see um an
example agenda from like a workshop I
did a few months back I just replaced
the functionality names with
placeholders um and you may be surprised
that for each functionality we have all
two hours um
dedicated uh and uh it may seem a lot
especially that those are quite simple
things like editing the data or even
filtering it but uh it was really needed
uh mostly because you know a lot of
happens during these two hours so uh
first of all there is some individual
work so we are sending the link to the
users and we are asking them to again go
through the app to f focus on this one
particular functionality to perform the
task that they would normally do uh and
then I am also in the room answering
questions looking how they are
interacting with the app so it is quite
similar to what I described before uh
but then during this process they have
time to note down some feedback that is
later discussed uh prioritized and then
again discussed so you can imagine that
if there's like 10 people in the room
probably the discussion can take some
time um and another point point is to
give an easy way to provide feedback but
you should also think about yourself
here and to make it easy later for you
to gather it and summarize
it what we usually do is uh we are
preparing for every separate
functionality a board like this uh with
the things that uh people liked in a
given functionality they didn't like uh
the things that are missing and are
obligatory they have to have them for to
be able to use the app and the things
that are missing and you know can be
implemented later somewhere in the
future um what I also current US started
doing um is that I also create another
space called parking lot that people can
add some you know random thoughts that
they had in mind just to not interrupt
during uh each
session and um the last point is to save
some time to prioritize so after um
every uh after all of the sessions it is
good to have additional one to just take
take you know three to five cards from
every uh board like this put them again
in one place and prioritize them and
discuss this prioritization and this
discussion is extremely important so for
example I've been in a situation that um
you know after this exercise I looked at
the cards and I saw that something that
I thought is super important based on
the conversations was somewhere at the
bottom uh so I asked the users uh why uh
is this the case and um they told me
that this is obvious that it needs to be
implemented and it wasn't obvious for me
so it would probably not be that obvious
for the development team as well that's
why uh I think this time to talk about
it is very important and usually the the
results of such workshops are just a
report with a list of priorities and a
short description about each priority uh
sometimes also if you can add some
simple visual uh visuals that can help
um and this report is later also very
useful during the development so if you
have reviews with the users you can even
go back to it uh you can discuss it and
show them that you are listening to them
and uh trying to implement the
improvements um and I told you at the
start that um user workshops and user
interviews work best uh in my projects
so now I want to just uh defend it a bit
so first of all uh it allows uh for a
detailed discussion something that I
mentioned I think few times during this
talk but um because of this you can
understand not only what people want you
to do but also why and then you can you
know suggest some
Alternatives but also you know have a
bigger picture and make sure that when
you are designing new feature you are
taking this into consideration so both
in the architecture but also in the ux
design another point is that uh you need
only 5 to 10 users which I think is not
a lot one thing to remember here is that
this group should be diverse so if
you're building something you know that
should work across departments probably
you should have people from different
departments uh the same from people from
different
regions and I would like to finish my
talk with another story this time a
success story and it started in the same
way so there was this manager with this
big amazing idea for a new tool that he
wanted to uh introduce in his
organization and he needed our help to
develop it so we learned from our
experience so even before starting a
project we talked with him to you know
be able to have some users involved in
the process uh but fortunately he was
very open for this he Not only was
talking with the users a lot about the
product but also he was open for us to
have those discussions what is more he
agreed to start with a prototype so just
after three weeks we already had
something that we could uh present to
the users and discuss with them we
decided to go with the user interviews
because it was still when Co was there
so we had to do it
online uh and you know the results of
this interviews were not as horrible as
the ones that I showed you before but we
learned that one of the main
functionalities um is not working in a
way that people are expecting it to work
in the end it wasn't a huge change from
the UI perspective but it was big enough
change that we had to redesign the data
architecture so imagine this happening
you know five months into development it
would be a real big change that would
influence a lot of
features um so we continued the
development and after just you know
additional five months we were able to
deploy uh the first version of the
application and the feedback was very
positive people were excited about it uh
currently the app is used by thousands
of users and uh we are still adding new
features so to summarize my
talk if you want to build a new
product and not go
bankrupt involve the end users early on
release
fast and don't forget about using the
real data so if you want to talk more uh
feel free to reach out to me on LinkedIn
I would be happy to discuss uh the
projects that you are doing and also
your challenges uh and here I also
wanted to thank posit for inviting me
and thank you all for joining here
[Applause]
today thank you Maria um we have time
for one quick question which sort of
aims at the advice to release fast do
you have any advice on how to balance
doing that in making a good impression
make a good impression I think that the
best uh like the best advice I would
give is to just start with a group of
users that you trust and you know that
you know we'll be open to seeing a tool
that is not
perfect uh because in the end it won't
be and it won't be it will be buggy it
won't be using work perfectly it
probably won't be the prettiest if you
want use B asleep so you can always uh
you know start with people that you
trust and people that you know are open
to seeing things that are not ideal
thank
you